what's going on guys this is rob and we
are continuing our series on omega level
mutants or beyond omega level means any
of you guys who are old enough to
remember when this series first started
we called it like omega and beyond omega
level mutants and then we just
shorthanded the name so like newcomers
are like that guy's not beyond omega
level and the old school fans are like
that's not exactly what the series means
even though that's what rob calls and
you probably should change it back to
the old name the important thing here is
we are continuing on with someone that
i'm surprised we never made a video on
charles xavier better known as professor
x so charles xavier was created by stan
lee and jack kirby and first appeared in
the x-men number one in 1963. now
xavier's father was a famous scientist
whose contributions to nuclear physics
made his family extremely wealthy and so
charles father dies while charles is a
young child and his mother remarries his
friend and partner curtin marco soon
after this charles mutant powers
manifests and he discovers that he has
the ability to read the minds of others
now charles is a naturally gifted
student and his mutant power makes him
even more successful academically but
also causes him to lose his hair at a
very young age he goes on to graduate
from college at the age of 16 and he
later goes on to become a professor at
both oxford and columbia university you
know something i've always wondered
british members of the rob core give me
the rundown on oxford in the in the
comment section is it like the english
version of like harvard or is it just
that high above every university
everywhere in the world like just let me
know like what's the ranking like if you
get like if you're accepted into oxford
is that like wow like man or is it like
cool i mean
i have a few friends to go there i mean
is that is that what it is
because i've always been kind of curious
but charles ends up falling in love with
a girl named maura in grad school and
the two become engaged but then charles
gets drafted into the army and fights in
the korean war during which time maura
breaks up with him and then marries an
abusive ex-boyfriend now in an attempt
to get over more mctaggart charles
begins traveling the world including a
stop in cairo egypt where he meets the
shadow king a mutant using his powers to
perpetrate crime now after the shadow
king nearly kills him charles dedicates
his life to promoting the harmonious
balance between humans and mutants now
the primary way he sought to do this was
through xavier's school for gifted
youngsters which he founded in the
mansion he'd grown up in to train a team
of mutant superheroes hoping that if the
world saw mutants using their powers for
good they'd be more accepting of mutant
kind the problem is the exact opposite
happened and that's the main reason
we've basically been reading 60 years of
x-men comics where professor x has
usually been leading a team of x-men and
they're trying in vain to accomplish his
dream now while there are many telepaths
within mama comics this is very
important charles xavier is arguably the
most powerful unlike some mutants who
have a variety of different powers
telepathy is the only power that xavier
possesses but he is so adept at it that
he's able to use it in incredible ways
at one point xavier was able to read
every mind on the planet simultaneously
and could feel their emotions as well as
reading their thoughts while that is
impressive in and of itself the range of
xavier's telepathy is not limited merely
to earth he's been able to contact the
x-men from halfway across the solar
system and was even able to reach
colossus and magneto on the space
station avalon from earth with another
omega-level telepath exodus running
psychic interference literally exodus
was trying to stop him and he was still
able to do it anyway to give you guys
perspective on this even jean grey as
powerful as she is doesn't seem to have
the same level of telepathy as charles
xavier unless she's in possession of the
phoenix force in more recent years
that's kind of changed and then she went
back to being her weaker self emma frost
has always kind of been up there but
still it's an impressive display now
xavier is able to do some pretty
interesting things with his telepathy
such as transferring feelings from one
individual to another for example when
the x-men were finding a group of aliens
and found themselves outmatched xavier
searched the world for people exhibiting
goodwill and compassion weeding out
those who were full of hatred prejudice
and cruelty and then transferred those
positive feelings to the x-men to give
them the positive energy they need which
somehow allows them to become more
powerful and defeat the aliens with your
feelings combined we are the x-men x-men
x-men we've got feelings i don't know
i'm let's ignore that
i love this thing anybody who's been
around this channel long enough knows i
love to sing i love to sing songs but on
a much larger scale xavier performed a
similar feat when he transferred the
emotions of the entire scroll homeworld
into the mind of galactus that was an
amazing moment in the comics but
professor xavier's telepathy is so
powerful juggernaut's helmet was unable
to stop it despite making him nearly
invulnerable to psychic attacks and
xavier has accomplished a similar feat
with magneto who also wears a telepathy
resistant helmet now xavier also
overpowered cyclops when cyclops was in
possession of half of the phoenix force
one of the most powerful entities in the
marvel universe and on another occasion
takes over the mind of both cyclops and
emma frost each of which have half of
the phoenix force at the time now even
though telepathy is his only power
xavier is able to use it in a variety of
ways he's also able to cause people to
forget things render himself invisible
and cause others to hallucinate feel
pain or become paralyzed he can take
full control of a person's mind is one
of the few telepaths that can actually
communicate with animals and can cause
others to lose their senses of sight
smell and hearing in some instances he's
even been able to shut off the mutant
abilities of others he's also shown
inability to reprogram the minds of
others as he did with wolverine during
their first encounter wolverine had
actually been sent to assassinate xavier
which is kind of cool but upon meeting
him xavier reprogrammed his mind so that
he believed his real purpose in coming
to xavier school was to join the x-men
now this reprogramming is not permanent
and wolverine's healing factor caused
his mind to revert to its original state
faster than it normally would have
similarly upon his first meeting with
jean grey xavier placed mental blocks in
her mind so she would not be aware of
her mutant powers because he believed
she was not yet able to control them now
an important distinction here is that
when it comes to jean grey's powers
really it was just her telepathy that
was blocked because it was overwhelming
for her she just simply couldn't control
it initially you didn't know that in
marvel comics and it wasn't until much
later i think during the arnold drake
run that you learned about that and then
you learned about it in the x-men
origins one shot that focused on on jean
grey there was a little bit of diving
into that with bizarre adventures number
27 back in the day by chris claremont
but nonetheless it's one of those things
you didn't really know right off the bat
but regardless xavier's telepathy allows
him to create psychic bolts that are
powerful enough to incapacitate or even
kill those he uses them on he can also
project his astral form into the astral
plane and within the astral plane create
objects and control or obliterate other
astral forms finally he's able to impart
his knowledge to others in a very short
amount of time so things that would take
months to learn happen in only hours
because xavier is able to alter the
perception of time within those that
he's telepathically connected to now
with all that said elephant in the room
in the most recent listing of omega
level mutants officially from marvel by
way of jonathan hickman's house of x and
powers of x professor xavier is not
listed so up to this point marvel's not
officially given professor x the
designation of omega level but i contend
that with everything we've seen him do
throughout the history of marvel comics
he should be first of all there are
mutants like apocalypse and nate gray
that are not on the list but are
definitely omega level mutants so i
don't think that we have to take this
list as being comprehensive second of
all xavier's widely regarded as the most
accomplished and powerful telepath in
existence and if we look at the feats
that he's accomplished with his
telepathy it's not a huge leap to put
him in the omega level category he's
connected the minds of every individual
on the planet without the aid of cerebra
which is good evidence that he could
affect the earth on a planetary scale if
he chose to which would be strong
evidence that he is omega level he's
also affected galactus telepathically
and is restrained individuals in
possession of the phoenix force which in
and of itself is an omniversal force so
if we look at the actual telepathic
feats he's achieved he seems more
deserving of a place on this list than
someone like jean grey or quentin choir
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you all
for watching make sure you leave a
comment down below letting me know who
else you want to see on our beyond omega
level series and i will catch you all
later
peace
you